[Applaudissements]
on se rend pas compte mais il ya dix ans
youtube n'existait pas twitter
n'existait pas facebook n'existait pas
10 15 ans donc évidemment que ça
bouleverse tous
moi je suis au coeur de l'action on est
en direct tout au long de la journée il
n'y a pas de coupure c'est en continuité
tous les lèvres que j'ai pu faire sont
toujours disponibles
après coup je pense le fait que beaucoup
de français de tous bords qui sont qui
sont dans la rue et donc les français de
plus en plus se disent ça peut m'arriver
à moi aussi l'opinion publique prend
conscience de ces violences policières
systémique
moi j'étais tout le temps en live pour
brut des centaines d'heures de direct en
immersion aucun des cortèges dans cette
vidéo on va essayer de vous expliquer
comment le maintien de l'ordre en france
à évoluer en seulement un an et demi
pour bien comprendre le maintien de
l'ordre dans l'histoire récente
en fait il faut remonter au milieu des
années 80 le 6 décembre 986 un jeune
étudiant malik oussékine meurt sous les
coups des policiers
c'est plus trois crs sortir de cet
immeuble avec un mec qu'ils ont
littéralement tabassés de façon
extrêmement violent donc à ce moment là
il ya des policiers à moto
ce sont des voltigeurs ce sont eux qui
tuent bien et que si clean de deux
policiers
le motard et son passager qui descendent
qui ne fera pas bon arrêt cardiaque
consécutive aux coups portés par les
policiers arrêt cardiaque dû à la peur
une enquête est ouverte par l'inspection
générale des polices pour déterminer les
circonstances exactes du décès de ce
jeune étudiant
c'est ce que la politique des
journalistes les policiers pour appeler
le syndrome malik oussékine c'était
l'idée que la police n'irai plus au
contact
le matador là à la française héritée des
années 80 notamment après la mort de
malik oussékine c'était une doctrine
dans laquelle on allait très peu au
contact on rester à distance des
manifestants ont considéré que la casse
matérielle n'était pas très grave
tant qu'il n'y avait pas de blessés
graves est encore plus grave un mort
pendant des années le modèle français on
va dire s'était montré sa force pour ne
pas s'en servir pour aller très vite
c'était contenir la foule c'était la
contenir à distance et on peut le dire
la france était plutôt bonne là dedans
jusqu'au moment des généraux
[Musique]
avec l'arrivée de gilet jaune il ya un
changement me donne
puisque les gilets jaunes refusent
d'organiser eux-mêmes leurs
manifestations refuse de les déclarer
auprès des forces de l'ordre refusent de
tout contact toute négociation en amont
sur le parcours et donc les forces
d'ordre non plus d'interlocuteur comme
c'était le cas avec les organisations
syndicales
donc il faut faire évoluer ce moteur de
l'ordre et en parallèle de ça il y a une
grande violence qui se déploie dans ces
manifestations de la part des
manifestants qui est réel qui dès le
début quasiment du mouvement des gilets
jaunes est plus importante que ce qu'on
a connu que ce qu'on a connu pareil on
remarque tout de suite que c'est un
mouvement qu'on peut considérer
d'insurrection en elle quelque part donc
avec beaucoup de tension des personnes
qui sont très en colère et des
manifestations qui déborde vraiment de
partout voilà si vous ne raisonnez en
leur direction
la situation est très tendue ici ce qui
est marquant sur les premières semaines
c'est voir des forces de l'ordre qui
sont dépassés en sous-effectif et qui
savent pas trop quoi faire face à ce
mouvement
en tout
c'est vrai que sur certains moments of
vous avez des membres des forces de
l'ordre qui peuvent venir se confier à
vous à dire que les ordres sont pas
adaptés à la situation qu'ils sont
fatigués qu'ils sont épuisés
moi c'est la première fois que je vois
en dehors des politiques on peut voir
blessés des policiers qui vont s'asseoir
sur un banc quelques minutes en disant
moi j'en peux plus je suis je suis ko
très rapidement ce qu'on remarque c'est
que toutes les forces de l'ordre sont
mobilisées et pas que celles qui sont
normalement destinés sur maintien de
l'ordre certes on retrouve des policiers
qui sont pas du tout formés à ça et
parmi ces forces là il ya notamment la
bac
les brigades anti criminalité ont été
créés pour intervenir dans les quartiers
populaires et ce sont ces brigades
anticriminalité qui ont été exportées
dont le maintien de l'ordre c'est à dire
qu'ils sont intervenus dans les
manifestations avec l'expérience qu'ils
avaient acquis dans les quartiers
populaires
on assiste finalement à une extension du
domaine de la violence policière des
quartiers populaires vers les
manifestations ce type de violences en
tout cas avec l' usage de ses armes
dites intermédiaires comme les lbd40
comme les grenades et ses armes il yal
cous énormément de dégâts et c'est
notamment à partir de ce moment là qu'on
remarque une multiplication des blessés
des mutilés au fur et à mesure des
manifestations
[Musique]
et si aujourd'hui on en parle de ces
violences c'est parce que les
manifestations sont désormais filmé sous
tous les angles en direct et ensuite les
images sont diffusées sur internet
[Applaudissements]
on sera complet il ya dix ans il
n'existait pas twitter n'existait pas
facebook n'existait pas 10 15 ans donc
évidemment que ça bouleverse tout ça
veut pas dire qu'avant il n'y a pas de
violences policières
non ça veut dire que elle n'était pas
diffusée aujourd'hui elles sont
diffusées
elles sont contextualisés c7
visibilisation par les vidéos parlent
usage des vidéos grâce au téléphone
portable grâce à la présence de
journalistes indépendants qui a permis
la visite vise à sion de ces violences
policières
la halle avantage c'est qu'on en direct
tout du long du début à la fin donc on à
l'événement déclencheur jusqu'à entre
guillemets sa résolution jusqu'à sa
forme
donc il n'ya pas de coupure c'est en
continuité et l'ensemble des vidéos
qu'on a pu tourner serre que tous les
lèvres que j'ai pu faire sont toujours
disponibles
après coup avec la diffusion de toutes
ces violences pendant le mouvement des
gilet jaune les français commencent à
s'interroger sur le maintien de l'ordre
dans le pays
mais c'est la mort d'un jeune nantais
dans un contexte festif qui va faire
prendre conscience à l'opinion publique
qu'il ya un problème avec la doctrine
policière actuelle
la police des polices saisie à nantes
après une opération controversée des
forces de l'ordre durant la fête de la
musique vendredi un jeune est toujours
porté disparu
fête de la musique sur les quais de
loire bred et dj la police arrive
demande au dj d'arrêter tous les dj art
est sauf un qui relance ses platines et
qui met un morceau des béruriers noirs
s'appelle port choix est une chanson
anti flics à 4h30 du matin la police
intervient pour faire cesser la musique
comme on le voit sur cette vidéo tournée
par des fêtes a très vite la situation
dégénère
vous avez des lacrymogènes des jets de
projectiles et ses charges de police
tombe dans la loire un certain nombre de
personnes et une ne remontera pas steve
moi je me suis rendu là-bas justement
pour brut pour faire un live pour
montrer un peu ce qui s'y passait pour
montrer les motions qui étaient énormes
justement dans cette ville il avait fait
une chaîne humaine face à la loire à
l'endroit où il avait disparu
steve de mon point de vue c'est
l'aboutissement d'un maintien de l'ordre
en roue libre puisque là a priori les
forces de police en présence c'est
plutôt des bacs
c'est plutôt des compagnies
d'intervention c'est plutôt des
policiers qui sont formés à l'anti
émeute pas du tout au maintien de
l'ordre
[Musique]
et la mort de steve elle rappelle
évidemment malik oussekine elle rappelle
les disparitions qui deviennent des
enjeux politiques
le fait qu'un jeune homme comme les
autres qui part faire la fête le soir de
la fête de la musique puisse trouvé la
mort au cours d'une opération de
maintien de maintien de l'ordre
ça semble inacceptable pour l'ensemble
des français l'opinion publique et prend
conscience de ces violences policières
systémique les violences policières
systémique ça veut dire une chose très
simple c'est qu'elles font système dès
lors qu'elles sont suffisamment
nombreuses pour considérer que ce ne
sont pas que des bavures et pas des
dérapages et après la mort de steve le
gouvernement il a plus vraiment le choix
il doit réagir
il ya une enquête qui a été déclenchée
par moi même
avant même d'ailleurs que nous apprenons
la disparition de ce jeune homme sur les
conditions dans lequelles l'opération
l'intervention policière a eu lieu
l'igpn l'inspection générale de la
police nationale est saisi l'igpn c'est
la lessiveuse
elle nous expliquait une charge de
police mais qu' il n'y a pas de lien
entre la charge de police et le fait que
des personnes aient plongé dans la loire
à ce moment là il ya une crise qui
s'instaure entre une partie de la
population la police le politique
je viens de faire un point de situation
avec monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
sur la disparition de monsieur steve
maya kenzo edouard philippe prend la
parole flanqué de christophe castaner
totalement muet sur le perron de
matignon à l'issue du travail de
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale des question reste donc posée
l'enchaînement des faits reste confus
je ne peux évidemment pas non satisfaits
cette phrase est intéressante parce que
il reconnaît qu'il ya quelque chose qui
va pas les gens ont peur de venir
manifester des gens qui venaient à
toutes les manifestations ne viennent
plus forcément c'est des choses qui
marquent et même encore aujourd'hui
enfin je veux dire faut pas oublier que
quand on est journaliste on est aussi
des êtres humains derrière avec une
sensibilité ces événements on les a
vécus en première ligne c'était des
situations humaines au travers ces
blessés qui étaient qui était assez dur
à vivre est assez prudente aujourd'hui
clairement la police française et le
gouvernement se cherche sur la question
du maintien de l'ordre quand un policier
comme est une violence est ce qu'ils les
responsables individuellement ou est-ce
que
il y a aussi une responsabilité de
l'état des autorités de sa hiérarchie
qui ne lui a pas donné les moyens qui ne
lui a pas donné la formation nécessaire
et cette responsabilité de l'état de
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
elle est rarement questionner le
maintien de l'ordre à la française c'est
quelque chose qui a existé mais qui a
été pulvérisée sous nos yeux
mois après mois semaine après semaine et
donc aujourd'hui on reparle constamment
du maintien de l'ordre à la française
mais mais en fait c'est un souvenir